Ja, begrüß die Leute.
Ja, erst letzte Woche versagst du von wegen, ich will dich auch mal dabei begrüßen, ich will auch mal dabei begrüßen, ich bin doof, dass du mal die Nacht hast. In dieser Woche ist mir alles egal, ich habe alles erreicht. Was ist los, Stefan, warum? Ich bin jetzt ein Star, weißt du, ich war bei Bild.de, ich war bei Welt.de, ich war, die Welt hat mich in Schutz genommen, bei Facebook-Kommentaren, die Zeitung, die Welt. Es hat ganze 20 Sekunden gedauert, damit Stefan schon mal mit hohem Sprung auf sein hohes Ross gesprungen ist. Okay, willst du noch ein paar Zeitungen aufzählen, wo du alles bekannt hast? Ja, ich bin Böhmermanns Wunderknabe. Das ist doch klar. Und wie alt bist du eigentlich? 19, immer noch. Ich bin seit drei Jahren nicht geallt. Du bist 38 bei deinem Erfolg. Gott, bei so einem Erfolg dachte ich immer an 38. Oh mein Gott. Doch, erst 19. Ja, aber wie bist du in die Medienbranche gekommen? Schön von Papa in die Firma eingeschlossen? Ja klar, mein Vater hat mich schön eingeschleust, hat das Hausmeister bei RTL, er hat mich reingelassen den Tag. Also für alle, die es nicht wissen, für alle minderwertigen Hörer, Stefan Titzel ist jetzt mittlerweile Presseorgan geworden und er hat sein eigenes Porträt bekommen in der Zeitung. Er wurde interviewt vor einiger Zeit von der dpa der deutschen Presseagentur. Und ich wurde reduziert auf mein Aussehen, auf mein Alter, auf seine Leistung, auf meine Leistung, auf seine Karriere, auf meine vielschichtigen Talente, auf meinen Podcast, ich wurde auf alles reduziert. Es war eine Frechheit, es war eine absolute Frechheit. Es wurde dir einfach nicht gerecht. Nein, das Ding ist, ich habe sehr viel über Neomagazine, ich habe nicht so viel über Neomagazine erzählt, sondern sehr viel über Podcasts auch und über gute Arbeit und so. Es ist leider alles nicht reingekommen. Ich hätte auch gerne, ich habe auch dich erwähnt sehr häufig, oft auch nicht unbedingt immer positiv, aber es ist nichts reingekommen davon. Dafür ein sehr schönes Zitat von dir, wo ich mich sehr darüber freue. Natürlich. Lest mal rein vielleicht. Klar, auf jeden Fall. Und drück auf Gefängnis. Und lass ein Like da. Lass ein Like da. Ja, apropos Like, wir haben heute eine erschreckende Statistik gefunden, und zwar, wir fragen uns ja immer, wie viele Leute hören uns überhaupt, also wie viele draußen, Leute sitzen ja gerade draußen am Strand mit dem Cocktail in der Hand und hören uns. Und wir haben eine Zahl, wir haben eine Zahl, wie viele ihr seid, also guckt mal nach links und rechts und jetzt hebt mal alle die Hand und schaut mal ganz kurz auf dem Strand, wie viele Leute ihr seid. Ihr seid 6520 Menschen. Und jetzt ist die Frage natürlich, wie geht's weiter? Wo geht's hin? Geht's nach oben, geht's nach unten? Und laut unserer analysierten Statistik seid ihr in zehn Jahren 6520. Es wird sich nichts ändern. Aber in fünfzehn Jahren, sechstausend fünfhundertzwanzig. Richtig. Obwohl man sagen muss, dass es nach 15 Jahren noch mal richtig rangeht, denn in 20 Jahren seid ihr 6520. Das Ding ist ja leider, dass die Analyse-Seite sehr, sehr sophisticated analysiert. Da kommen viele Sachen ins Spiel. Da ist keine Bannerwerbung an der Seite. Da sind viele Zahlen, viele Prozentzahlen. Das kommt mir an und denkt sofort, geil. Genau, die schmeissen die Formel um sich und berechnen da ganz tolle Zahlen, um in Zukunft zu gucken, auch seinen Werbeträgern zu sagen, so viele Leute erreichen uns eigentlich. Und bei uns ist es wirklich, man kann sagen, solide. Also unser Wachstum ist gleichbleibend, nicht vorhanden. Ich glaube, das ist sowieso so ein Ding, das in der Internetbranche ein viel klotzigeres Verhalten gibt. Ich würde es klotzig nennen. Weil bei einer Fernsehsendung, da hast du eine Quote und wenn die scheiße wird, dann reduziert sich die Quote teilweise um die Hälfte. Dann bist alle weg und dann keiner mag dich mehr. Aber bei YouTube deabonnieren die Leute in der Regel nicht so stark, wie sie sagen würden. Weil der Algorithmus das auch selber übernimmt und dann einfach sagt, der zeigt dir deine Videos nicht mehr an, wenn du es nicht mehr magst, das heißt, du behältst deine Abos immer, das heißt, der Werbepartner, weiß nicht, was ist da los, wie viele schauen es denn wirklich an. Du wirst doch langweilt von der eigenen Aussage, so ein Gän zwischendurch, ja komm, komm mal so ein Endi, so erschöpft vom eigenen Reden, aber du hattest mich beim Wort Quote. Leute, das ist ja auch spannend,
weil es gibt so tolle Kurven, die man manchmal sieht,
Verlaufskurven von verschiedenen Sendungen.
Und man kann sehen, bei manchen Gags
und bei manchen Themen gehen Kurven hoch.
Wenn eine Sendung gut wird, gehen Kurven hoch.
Komischerweise, weil es macht keinen Sinn.
Es müssen ganz viele Leute, die müssen
vorm Fernseher sitzen, das Gefühl haben,
wow, schalt mal kurz auf RTL, schalt mal kurz auf RTL,
da versichert was Großes.
Ja, ich glaube, da tritt gleich Carmen Niosk auf. Und alle schalten auf RTL und die Kurve geht plötzlich hoch. Wenn irgendwas die Fähigkeiten, Hellsehkräfte beweist, dann Fernsehquoten. Das war immer das Abgefahrenste, auch beim Neo Magazin, dass man eine Sendung gemacht hat und am nächsten Tag kamen die Quoten und es hieß, die Quoten waren hoch, es war eine geile Sendung. War eine gute Sendung. Und ich habe mir immer gedacht, das ergibt ja überhaupt keinen Sinn. Doch, es ergibt voll Sinn. Aber man weiss doch nicht, bevor man einschaltet, ob die Sendung gut wird oder nicht. Ich habe immer ein Gefühl. Ich habe immer ein Bauchgefühl, wird die Sendung gerade gut, wird die Sendung gerade schlecht. Es müsste sich doch eigentlich erst an der nächsten Sendung aufzeichnen, dass die Leute sagen, ah, die war gut, ich schaue die nächste an und sage auch noch viel meinen Freunden Bescheid. Ja, ich bin naiv, ich bin Träumer, ich bin Träumer, ich Ich bin blödi, ich bin Träumer, ich bin naivling, ich weiß, das ist mein Problem. Das Wort Blödian, ist es auch irgendwie, woher kommt, also warum, warum sagt man dann, ich meine, man sagt auch nicht, das ist auch so, ach Leute, denkt euch mal neue Sachen aus. Blödian, dieses einfach Ihan dranhängen, weißt du, das ist auch. Welches Schimpfwort hast du als letztes weißt du, das ist auch Welches Schimpfwort hast du als letztes
nicht ironisch verwendet?
Welches Schimpfwort hast du als letztes, also hast du
wirklich in deinem letzten Mal gesagt, du bist echt ein Arschloch?
Also was war's? Meinst du jetzt direkt
gegenüber Leuten? Ja. Oder auch
im Straßenverkehr? Mir ins Gesicht gesagt,
nee, nicht Straßenverkehr, sondern einfach
im Straßenverkehr benutzt du das F-Wort häufig.
Ja? Du guckst euch aus,
welches F-Wort?
Fürsorge.
Richtig.
Aber nee, was war das letzte?
VW.
Was war das letzte?
Ich glaube, Schwachkopf, glaube ich, so was. Vollidiot oder Schwachkopf.
Schwachkopf?
Ja.
Und das hast du an jemanden einfach an den Kopf geworfen oder was? Du Schwachkopf.
Ja, mit dem Opa.
Du Schwachkopf, ja klar, das ist ein Wort, was man benutzen kann. Ich finde, Schwachkopf hat auch so einen schönen Klang, so einen schönen vorwurfsvollen Klang, voll idioten Schwachkopf finde ich okay, ja, das kann man auch aber härter wird es bei dir auch nicht, ne? ne, aber wir sind auch keine Streiter also ich, gar nicht, überhaupt nicht aber wir sind auch nicht so, dass wir uns zurückziehen also ich suche schon die Konfrontationen aber dann eher mit Argumentieren und so einem Diskurs. Ja, und weinen auch viel. Und viel Mitleid erzeugen. Also ich habe auch gemerkt, dass wenn man sich eines Streites naht und dann anfängt zu weinen, hören die Leute auf zu streiten. So, dann geht dann eher so dieser fürsorgliche Instinkt über, deswegen ist es bei mir oft der erste Moment weinen. Oder laut durch die Nase ein- und ausatmen. Ja, das ist auch gut. Genau, nicht mehr reden, sondern nur noch ... So ein bisschen zittern, dass das ganze Gesicht so ein bisschen zittert, da haben Leute Angst. Ich glaube, bei mir war es Pfeife. Ich glaube, das einzige Schimpfwort, das ich ernsthaft benutze, ist Pfeife. Weißt du, du bist echt eine Pfeife. Ich finde auch teilweise, dass schwächere Beleidigungen einen stärkeren Effekt haben können. Dann schreibt man dem eine grössere Objektivität zu. Weißt du, das ist echt ein verwichstes Arschloch. So, dann denkt man sich so, ja gut, der ist halt gerade flucht. Das ist maximal, genau. Das ist eine Aussage eher über den, der gerade flucht, nicht über mich. Aber wenn jemand sagt, weißt du was, du bist echt eine Pfeife, so, dann denkt man sich, okay, das meint er jetzt ernst, weil das ist nicht so emotional durchdrungen. Richtig, genau. Das ist zu viel. Also voll gewichstes HurenarsArschloch. Das ist zu viel, da steckt zu viel drin, zu viel Anstrengung auch. Du ekelhafte Eitertittenmaus. So, da sagt man, ja. Du widerliches, holzschnittsartiges Gesicht. Ja. Das ist zu viel, Leute. Du Tropfkopf. Ihr legt dann zu viel, ach, alles piept einfach hier, ohne Scheiß. Unsere Aufnahmenbedingungen sind einfach lächerlich mittlerweile. Aber es ist ja auch so, und dafür fühle ich mich persönlich angegriffen, dass wenn du gerade am Mac-Laptop sitzt und dann wirst du auf dem iPhone angerufen. Why? Dann wirst du auf dem iPhone angerufen. Mein Gott, lass mich doch mal ein bisschen zack mit reinbringen. Das Wort Laptop lässt sich ausgesprechen, so als wäre es ein Ding, was sind so die Reichen. Am Laptop, aha. Und dann wird ich auf meinem Smartphone. Und dann ist die auf meinem Stuhl. Und dann ruft mich jemand an, auf meinem Smartphone. Und dann ruft mich jemand an, auf meinem iPhone. Und dann hast du aber auch den Anruf auf dem Laptop. Ja! Und dann gehst du an, ja, ich weiss es doch. Mein Gott, musst du nicht die Stecker alle draufziehen. Oh, ist das voll egal. Und dann nehme ich den Anruf auf dem iPhone an, dann klingelt es aber auf dem Laptop weiter, aber hört auch nicht auf, auch wenn ich den Anruf führe, hört es einfach nicht auf. Das heißt, jeder Anrufer, der mich normal bei meiner Workstation anruft, hört die ersten zehn Minuten des Telefonats die ganze Zeit. Bei mir hört, also bei mir ist es das Folgende, ich habe ja ein Smart Home, bei mir ist alles miteinander verbunden, die Lampen reden mit den Taschentüchern, du niest einmal laut und schon geht die Heizung um 10 Grad hoch. Und schon sagt das Haus geschlossen Gesundheit, alle Devices, alles ist miteinander verbunden und wenn ich einen Anruf bekomme, bimmelt alles. Die Wohnung ist, deswegen stelle ich mich mal in die Mitte der Wohnung, um laut zu reden, weil ich nicht genau weiss, welches Device hört mich gerade, welches nimmt mich auf.
Alle sagen, du wirst gerade angerufen, das ist einfach so, das ich nicht genau weiß, welches Device hört mich gerade, welches nimmt mich auf.
Alle sagen, du wirst gerade angerufen, es ist einfach so das Hausfertig grün, so ein grüner Hörer.
Es vibriert, die Scheiben zittern einfach alles.
Ich weiß nicht genau, wenn ich jetzt auf irgendeinen Knopf drücke, weiß nicht, mit welchem Device ich spreche, ist es die Mikrowelle, ist es der Tiefkühltoster, keine Ahnung.
Und dann stelle ich mich in die Mitte der Wohnung und rufe dann ganz laut, hallo?
Ja, bei TheChangeman, wo ich ab und zu einen Podcast aufnehme, der hat auch so
dieses Alexa-System zu Hause von Amazon und da kann er auch das Licht steuern. Und dann kann er immer sagen, Licht im Flur auf 80 Prozent. Und dann geht er auf 80 Prozent, das kann er alles so dimmen. Und dann mache ich immer, Licht im Flur auf 79 Prozent. Licht im Flur auf 79,5 Prozent. Das tut sich nichts, aber ich denke immer so. Licht im Flur auf Pi. Nimm das. Licht im Flur auf Wurzel von 628%. Einfach so eine Lightshow geht plötzlich dann los. Ja, und das ist echt immer so verrückt, weil die gesamten Rechenkapazität geht nur darauf, das Licht genau perfekt zu treffen. Einfach so wirklich auf der vierten Nachkommestelle so hin und her. Bei mir war es dann so enden, dass die Lampen gar nicht für Dimm geeignet sind, einfach platzen. Ja, das stimmt. Licht im Flur auf, wie alt ist Keanu Reeves Prozent. Aber erstmal gucken. 47, glaube ich. Aber der bescheisst manchmal. Das ist kein Witz, der bescheisst. Ja, der bescheitert. Ja, das ist so, wenn du sag sagst, Wurzel von 33, das packt er noch, dann Wurzel von 333, sagt er irgendwas, passt auch, Wurzel von 333 und irgendwann fängt er einfach an zu lügen. Er nennt Zahlen, die so in der Richtung, aber es stimmt nicht. Aber ist er auch selbstbewusst? Aber er überschlägt, mega selbstbewusst, aber er scheint sowas zu überschlagen, weil dies in der Anzahl der Zahlen dann schon stimmt dieses Ergebnis, aber es ist einfach nicht korrekt. Das heißt, er scheint einfach zu bluffen. Unterstellst du ihm jetzt, genau, unterstellst du ihm eine Lüge oder unterstellst du ihm einen Rechenfehler? Glaubst du, er weiß, dass es gerade falsch ist? Das weiß ich nicht, das ist ein Mysterium. Das ist für mich eine lustige Vorstellung, dass er einfach anfängt. Ich kenne nur dieses Video, wo das Kind, so ein süßes kleines Kind sich einen Song wünscht und Alexa nur Quatsch versteht. Also das Kind ist dann irgendwie so, ja, einmal einen Winnie-Pooh-Song bitte. Und dann versteht Alexa aber, oh, Porn, Lesbian, You Porn, XXX, Midget, Helicopter-Midget. Und dann geht es einfach, alle Eltern schreien dann so, wo, stopp, stopp, Alexa,
stopp! Ja, da gab es aber auch so
einen Vorfall, dass in irgendeiner Werbung
in der Werbung
irgendwie so ein Alexa-Command
eingebaut wurde, sodass alle Kinder,
die diese Werbung auf dem Fernseher schauen,
sofort das Alexa anspringt und automatisch
irgendein Spiel bestellt. Aber kann Alexa,
ey, kann Alexa... Also das war ein Fake, das war ein Hoax,
das stimmt nicht. Aber das ist eine geniale Idee.
Man kann auch Dinge bestellen mit Alexa. Ja, genau.
Wenn die Werbung dann einfach sagt,
zweimal Tempo-Daschentücher,
bitte, und dann einfach
verkauft er das einfach. Bestellt er das, dann kannst du nichts damit gar nicht machen.
Oder du lässt wie bei so dieses, eine übergriffige Werbung,
Loose Clues,
Blues Clues, Blues Clues,
wo die Kinder immer so nach... Du musst es nicht sprechen wie ein Blues singen.
Blues Clues. Wo die Kinder das immer nachsprechen müssen, kannst du auch einfach sagen, und jetzt alle, Alexa, bestell vier Krankenversicherungen bei Quarta Consoras. Alexa, Alexa, bestell vier Krankenversicherungen bei Quarta Consoras. Ja, mach dich arm. Alexa ist toll. Wollten wir nicht mal einen Alexa haben als dritten Host? Ja, das war schon lange ein grosser Traum, weil ich dann immer sagen wollte, so Alexa, die Sendung ist gerade nicht so geil, Alexa, erzähl mal einen Witz und dann einfach zu schauen, was passiert. Aber gib uns einen Stichwort, gib uns ein Thema, dann hat man ein Thema. Was treibt dich gerade um? Welche Themen auf der Welt? Staub, Schaltkreise. Wenn Alexander sowas sagt, dann müssen wir auch on point anfangen, darüber zu improvisieren. Weißt du, das kriegen wir hin? Nee. Glaube ich nicht. Können wir mal ganz kurz Werbung machen für unseren Impro-Podcast? Klar. Gute Arbeit Impro. Könnt ihr euch anhören auf Soundcloud oder auf iTunes mit der bezaubernden Katjana Gerns und Leonie Kupke machen wir Improvisations-Comedy. So, kann man auch mal sagen. Kann man auch mal machen. Ist okay. Wird auch besser. Hört mal rein. Für mich ist ein bisschen die Welt zusammengebrochen neulich, als ich was gehört habe, und zwar ist ein Bekannter mit einem Pferd geflogen. Okay, ein paar Fragen. Nein, bevor du Fragen stellst, kannst du das Ende des Referats anführen. Der ist mit dem Pferd geflogen nach, umsonst kann man dann fliegen, wenn man mit dem Pferd fliegt, weil das die Firma, diese Pferde Transportfirma bezahlt. Und zwar fliegt, ist er geflogen von Deutschland nach L.A. Und dann kannst du nicht einfach das Pferd unten im Gepäckraum lassen und kannst oben sitzen. Nein, du musst eine halbe Stunde lang, musst du zum Pferd. So. Während des Flugs. Während des Flugs musst du eigenständig, autonom. Sagt das Pferd oder was? Nein, sagt die Luftfahrtrichtung, Vorschrift. Sondern musst du aufstehen, kannst eigenständig, aus eigenem Willen in den Maschinenraum des Flugzeugs gehen, wo dann das Pferd steht und du kannst... Steht da nicht einfach so da rum oder in so einer Box oder sowas? Da steht ein Pferd in einem kleinen Stall in einem Flugzeug. Wie grossartig ist das denn bitte? In einem Stall schon. In so einer Art, in so einem Zaun. Und da ist ja noch Heu und sowas, oder wie? Ja, ich glaube schon. Und dann musst du dem halt Apfel geben oder sowas. Ist das nicht mega kalt in dem? Ist das so minus 20 Grad? Bei mir haben sich so viele Fragen gebildet. Das war mindblowing. So und dann erst mal, wie cool ist es denn, dass du eigenständig einfach aufstehen kannst und dann einfach mal, und da werden auch ganz viele andere Sachen planen, Tücher. In welche Tür geht man denn da hin? Ja, das habe ich mich auch gefragt. Einfach ans Ende des Flugzeugs hieß es dann, das wäre das Normalste der Welt. Einfach ans Ende des Flugzeugs, das ist so eine Tür, da kannst du reingehen und dann eröffnet sich eine neue Welt und du siehst erstmal, wie groß das Flugzeug wohl ist und dann bist du in so einer eigenständigen Welt, wo so ein ganz Parallelkosmos stattfindet, einmal so Flüchtlingsfamilien liegen dann da rum und feiern, so um die Hühner tanzen.zen das ist also die die dritte klasse so die da drunter ist ja gepäckraum und da sind dann auch pferde einfach so die stehen dann einfach darum und dann musst du ab und zu dann streichen und beruhigen und füttern ja dann kannst du einfach das gepäck von allen anderen leuten klauen oder was ja das weiß ich nicht was getrennt ist aber das ist schon spannend oder das ist schon abgesehen und dann ist er umsonst geflogen für diese. Und dann mussten die halt... Gibt's da Fenster? Kann das Pferd rausschauen? Was denkt sich denn das Pferd eigentlich? Was ist denn hier gerade los? Was geht denn gerade jetzt ab? Leute, alles vibriert. Ich hab einen Druck auf den Ohren, einen wahnsinnigen Ich hab Riesenohren. Und ich hab wahnsinnigen Hunger auf Tomatensaft. Kann man einen Tomatensaft bringen? Und ich hab jetzt schon alle Erdnüsse gegessen. Das fand ich schon sehr faszinierend. Weil die müssen ja auch durch die Sicherheitsvorkehrungen. Das frage ich mich. Und da kann man denen eine Waffe geben, die die dann essen. Ah, jetzt wird es interessant. Und dann in den Maschinenraum gehen, sagen und warten, bis das Pferd mal muss. Ist dann töten. Vielleicht dann töten. Töten, aufschneiden. Aus dem Magen die Uzi holen und dann oben in Maschinenraum gehen, sagen und warten bis das Pferd mal muss, vielleicht dann töten,
aus dem Magen die Uzi holen
und dann oben im Maschinenraum
ordentlich Rambazamba
machen.
Es entwickelt doch ganz neue Möglichkeiten
des internationalen Terrorismus.
Und vor allem, wenn du erwischt wirst, kannst du sagen,
ich weiß ja nicht, was das Pferd macht.
Das Pferd ist ja auch selbstständig auf eine gewisse Art.
Das ist ja sein eigenes Ding.
Also der Rat des Anwalts, wenn sie gefragt werden, ob sie die Tatwaffe untergebracht haben, dann antworten sie
Und das machen sie so 12, 14 Minuten lang.
Florentin, du hast dich doch wieder mit der Susanne getroffen. Okay, dann nicht. Sie kommen aus jeder Situation raus. Ja, mit dem Färd mitgekommen. Ja, dann ist sie jetzt einfach da rum. Dann fielst du einfach mit dem Pferd. Und dann dachte ich auch. Aber das musste ich jetzt nicht anschnallen oder so.. Also ich meine, ich finde das mein, vor allem reitest du dann zum Flughafen und dann fliegt die beide in die Wildnis und dann aus dem Flugzeug raus und dann direkt mit dem Pferd. Ich dachte immer, das Gepäck ist in den Tragflächen. Nee, da ist der Treibstoff. Nee, in den Tragflächen ist der Treibstoff. Ja, da ist der Treibstoff. Ja. Ja. So, so, okay. Aber dann. Aber das Gepäck, der Kofferraum sozusagen, der ist unter dem Korpus des Flugzeugs. Ich bin doch mit Ryan geflogen, da wurde mir gesagt, dass die viele Kabel rausnehmen haben lassen. In welcher Konversation ist das aufgekommen? So ein komischer Satz. Kann ich noch einen Tee haben? Ja, wir haben aber viele Kabel, gerade die Isolierungsteile, aus unserem Maschinenraum rausgenommen. Wir haben mehr Tee, weil wir Platz sparen. Wir haben viele Kabel. Dafür haben wir nur Tee jetzt da. Ich weiß, was war dein Kapitän. Wir haben unsere Reiseflügel erreicht, obwohl wir ein paar Kabel weniger haben. Überrascht mich jetzt auch persönlich. Haben wir wahrscheinlicherweise die Reisefluktu erreicht, obwohl wir ein paar Kabelbinger haben, haben wir überraschenderweise die Reisefluktu erreicht. Das ist das Ziel. Ankommen ist jetzt nur noch Bonus.
zweitrangig erstmal, aber jetzt erstmal geniesst erstmal diesen Moment.
Die wollen wohl, um Benzin zu sparen,
maximal leicht. Die haben auch Sitze mehr
eingebaut, also es gibt noch mehr Sitze bei Ryanair,
du hast auch weniger Platz und sowas, und die haben auch
um Platz und
Gewicht zu sparen, haben die Kabel rausnehmen lassen. Die haben teilweise Vierfachversicherungen, Kabel rausnehmen lassen, jetzt gibt es nur noch zwei davon und sowas. Das heißt, du fliegst mit Ryanair maximal unsicher. Also das ist wirklich schon spannend. Das ist auch krass, finde ich, wenn das dann so übergriffig wird auf die Sicherheit. Klar, die Sicherheit stirbt zuerst. Das habe ich schon sehr oft gesagt. Richtig oft. Du warst im Flug... Nee, wo bist du denn gingflogen? Berlin! Berlin! Da warst du doch, du bist nicht zugefahren. Ja, das war schön. Bist du in der ISE Erstklasse gefahren? Nee, in der Erstklasse, schön, Zweite Klasse. Aber das war auch so ein klassischer Moment, wo wir ja auf ja auf dieser tausend Jahre Funkveranstaltung waren. Ich muss da nochmal zurückdenken. Und da war es dann auch die Situation, dass ich recht früh gegangen bin, weil so und weil ich noch einen zweiten Job hatte. Und dann bin ich da rausgegangen zu allen, weil das Problem ist, wenn du gehst von einer Veranstaltung, musst du erstmal durch die Raucher. Oh no. Das heißt, erstmal musst du innerhalb des Raumes dich verabschieden und alles und so und dann cool und du machst deine Gags und so. Ne, geil, wir sehen uns nächste Woche und nächstes Jahr und die nächsten 2000 Jahren. Viel Spaß und so. Ich taue mir bei unserem Channel vorbei, wir müssen unbedingt mal was zusammen machen. Und dann gehst du raus und denkst du, geil, aber dann kommen noch die Raucher, so der letzte Level, die Raucher. Und die haben aber auch dieses, ich nenne es mal eine entspannte Gelassenheit, mit der sie dich nicht gehen lassen wollen. Richtig, richtig. Und dann sagen die Leute am lautesten, was haust du schon ab, mit dem du den Abend eh nichts mehr gesprochen hättest. Ja, weil du kommst auch oft in so ein Gesprächsvakuum rein. Ich habe das Gefühl, bei Rauchern ist dann oft so ein halbes Gespräch am Laufen, aber die freuen sich, wenn jemand kommt, den wir so packen können. Weil die sind die sind ja auch ein eingeschwalter Haufen, wo die dann einfach da schon ihre Themen haben und die haben sie durch. Die treffen sich ja auch oft zum gleichen Zeitpunkt und abends im Laufe des Abends, um ihre Gespräche durchzuführen. Und du kannst dir deinen Gesprächspartner nicht aussuchen als Raucher, du musst mit anderen Rauchern sprechen, die im Zweifelsfall langweilig sind. Das heißt, du kommst da rein und stehen da halt so cool Leute, steht da halt in Etienne Gade irgendwie, weißt du, dann steht da halt in Horst Steiner und so und dann redest du halt mit denen und dann so geil, cool, okay, dann musst du da nochmal schauen, jetzt kommt ein cooler Abgang und kriegst du da nochmal einen cooler Abgang und dann laufe ich über den Hof weg zu den ersten Schranke und es war halt einfach Winter und sauglatt. Ich bin erst mal direkt ausgerutscht, einfach so in vollem View, weil alle haben noch gelacht und alle waren noch laut und haben mir so hinterher geguckt, so wirklich so so Kopfschilden so, wie macht der das, wie macht der das?
Ich weiß nicht, ob du mein Reiseoutfit kennst, ich bin ja viel unterwegs. Und wenn ich unterwegs bin, normal, erstmal dicke Jacke, Rucksack und dann über den Rucksack nochmal so ein Jutebeutel, wo nochmal Kleidung drin ist. Das heißt, ich bin sehr tief als Objekt, ich habe eine hohe Tiefe. Und das heisst, ich bin ausgerutscht, bin auf den Rücken gefallen,
lag dann auf meinem Jutebeutel und auf meinem Rucksack,
die Schildkröte, wirklich so eineinhalb Meter in der Höhe
und konnte nicht aufstehen, weil ich war die Schildkröte,
musste mich dann erstmal so zur Seite wuchten und zur Seite umfallen,
um mich dann aufstellen zu können.
Und das war wirklich so die maximale Demütigung.
Oh Gott.
Ich kucke mir direkt und denk einfach so, seh schon dieses und denk einfach so, und denk einfach so, und denk einfach, ja, fickt euch einfach. Alles, was du an dem Abend aufgebaut hast, so ich hatte eine coole Lehntechnik, ich hab ein paar geile Gags geheirrt, und alles ist kaputt in dem Moment, in dem du einfach die Schildkröte machst und auf deinem Jutebeutel so hin und her dödelst, Beine strampeln, durch die Gegend nach oben wie so ein Hund im Wasser. Ist jemand zur Hilfe geeilt? Nein. Nehmen wir auch nur einen Handfeil. Rauchen, hallo, nein, auf keinen Fall. Nein, nein, nein, das wird nichts. Aber ich habe noch mit Etienne Gaudi gesprochen und er meinte, das war noch Gesprächsthema und wurde noch gut aufgenommen. Aber er geht, kein Problem. Ja, aber dein Reiseoutfit ist schon spannend. Weil ich bin, ich bin auch ein typischer Rucksackreiser. Aber ich finde, also ich bin ein großer Fan, glaube ich, weiss ich nicht, ich habe es noch nicht ausprobiert, aber ich hätte, glaube ich, eher so einen One-Suit, diesen einfach so einen, dass man so einen Overall. Mantel meinst du? Overall. Overall? Ja, einfach, ich glaube, so eine bequeme, so eine Ganzkörper-Jogginghose einfach, mit einem Reisverschluss, den man vorne so zuzieht. Und was hätte ich gerne einfach, dass man so maximal cozy, so maximal coziges Gefühl hat und dann durch die Welt läuft. Das hätte ich, glaube ich, gerne. Ich weiß aber nicht, ob das so praktisch ist. Stell dir vor, es juckt, dein Oberschenkel juckt. Was machst du dann? Juckse. Nee, du musst ja erstmal Rausverschluss auf, da musst du dich da so durchschlemmeln. funktioniert nicht. Aufs Klo gehen ist auch nicht so einfach, da machst du dann von unten oder von oben, ist schwierig. Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob dieser One-Suit so, ich glaube, wenn du zu Hause bist und kuschelst und du mit der neuen Staffel Sherlock da sitzt, weiss nicht, ob wir da noch drüber reden wollen, aber da hatten wir schon hitzige Diskussionen. Aber ich weiss nicht, ob es so ein noch... Also bei mir ist auf jeden Fall die Jogginghose und dann einfach der Jutebeutel. Ja. Und dann einfach immer im ECE Jutebeutel und Jacke nach oben, Rucksack neben mir und dann wunderbar. Ja, mein Rucksack geht auch sehr weit in die Tiefe und oft ist es so, wenn ich mich drehe, dass viele Leute Augenlicht verlieren, einfach weil auch die Dornen, die ich meinen im Rucksack befestigt habe, um gefährlicher auszusehen.
Und die Rasierklingen, die raus in der Punkerzeit da hängen.
Der Nietengürtel dann einfach durch die Augen.
Ich wurde neulich von einem Opa, von einem Senioren, wurde ich ziemlich doll zurechtgewiesen, dass mein Rucksack verletzend ist für die Umwelt.
Meine Antwort war, ja genau.
Ich nehme den Menschen nicht mehr ernst.
Ich lache nur noch über sowas.
Kann ich nur drüber lachen.
Ja. Ach ja, Rucksäcke.
Ja, Rucksäcke.
Was ist bei dir in der
Rucksack-Vordertasche drin?
Oh, Kopfschmerz-Sabletten. Ja, wirklich, das ist eigentlich das echte MTV Cribs. Was die Handtasche vielleicht für eine Frau ist, ist für mich auf jeden Fall die Vordertasche vom Rucksack. Was ist da drin? Es ist drin, kann ich dir sagen. Ladekabel bei mir? Nee, das ist in der mittleren, im Littonfach, im Hauptfach. Achso, ich habe nur ein grosses und ein kleines.
Ich habe vorne ein Fach, das grosse Fach und das dahinter das Laptopfach.
So, ich fülle dich mal kurz durch meinen Rucksack.
Alles klar.
Ganz vorne findest du Kopfhörer, diese kleinen Kopfhörer, innen die Kopfhörer.
Ich trage meistens meine Neusskanzlinge Kopfhörer, die grossen.
Moment, die sind in der grossen Tasche?
Nee, in der kleinen Tasche vorne weg.
Ja, aber lösen sich da nicht die Nobbel ab?
Mhm.
Aber ist das nicht schlecht? Ja, es ist schlecht, aber alle anderen Alternativen im Rucksack wären noch schlechter. Was ist mit der Hosentasche? Da vertrage ich die nicht häufig genug. Es sind sogar zwei. Auch ein Problem mit One-Suits. Ich habe zwei Arten der Kopfhörer, zwei sind drin, einmal In-Ears und einmal diese Apple-Dinger, weil
der Anschluss vom iPhone einfach scheiße ist.
Danach ist ein Notizbuch
drin, ein Stand-up-Notizbuch,
wo ich mir mal vorgenommen habe, Dinge reinzuschreiben.
Es steht drauf, die erste Seite
ist beschrieben, Stefan Thiese,
dann gibt es so einen Reward, wenn man das findet, wo ich glaube ich
fünf Dollar reingeschrieben habe und
ich glaube, es ist ein Satz drin geschrieben.
Die fünf Dollar sind auch schon drin, hinten. Die Belohnung ist schon drin. Die Belohnung ist dieses Buch. Witze. Das finde ich nicht schlecht, wenn jemand mein Witzebuch klappt. Glaubst du, wenn ich das Louis C. K. Witzebuch finden würde, dass man es einfach so auf der Bühne machen könnte oder dass man es nicht versteht? Schwierig. Weil bei mir ist, danke, danke für den Kommentar, ja, schwierig. Und bei mir ist dann ich glaube ich ein Satz drin, den ich nicht mehr verstehen kann, weil ich den, also einen Fiebertraum aufgeschrieben habe und das ergibt keinen Sinn mehr. Und Kaufmannstabletten sind drin, das ist mein erstes Fach. Bei mir ist eine Kaugummi-Box drin, dieser Kanister Kaugummi, der immer so halb voll ist, der auch dazu führt, dass wenn ich laufe, immer Ratter eigentlich, immer Klapper, wirklich auch Treppen, da wird ordentlich geklappert. Ja, wie Mittelalter-Pädophile, die man einfach mit so einer Klapper versehen hat, damit Verbrecher die erkennen und Kinder fliehen können. Das ist quasi die moderne Art der Klapper, einfach so eine Kaugummi-Box. Das hat auch niemand normal, das hat diese dicke Kaugummi-Box, die ist unpraktisch. Nee, die ist total praktisch, das ist einfach eine Menge. Ja, gut, aber ist das eine Menge drin? Da ist viel drin. Und ich kaufe dann auch oft so diese Pillendinger, wo man diese aus dem Plastik so rausstanzen muss und fülle damit die Dose wieder neu auf. Wow! Ja, ja, ja, ja, manchmal sind da auch Streifen drin, manchmal sind da Tragees, sogar Kaugummi. Streifen da drin? Ich weiß nicht, ab irgendeinem Punkt in meinem Leben habe ich mich dazu entschlossen, immer Kaugummi dabei zu haben. Aber ich sehe dich selten Kaugummi kauen. Naja, das war vielleicht, glaube ich, aus meiner Studienzeit geschuldet, als ich einfach mir jeden Tag schönen Döner reingedrückt habe und mir dachte, ja, warst du eigentlich ein Kaugummi? So, weil danach geht es wieder irgendwie, dann machst du wieder mit den heißen Philosophiestudern hin und rum, da brauchst du einfach ein, zwei Kaugummis und die Lektüreausgabe Hegel, so und dann geht es los. Mehr brauchst du nicht. Und deswegen habe ich mich dazu Ladekabel immer drin. Ja, nein, klar. Ladekabel ist drin. Würfel, immer Würfel drin. Auf jeden Fall. Und irgendwelche Zettel. Irgendwelche alten Tickets oder so sind auch noch drin. Viele Quittungen, USB-Festplatte. Und immer eine Wasserflasche. Nicht da vorne drin, aber im Hauptfach immer eine Wasserflasche. Ganz wichtig. Ja, es wird auch nicht mal, ich glaube, ich habe eine Sonnenbrille noch drin. Nossätzlich eine Sonnenbrille. Falls du mal cool sein musst. Ein Fisherman's Friends ist immer noch eng. Für Notfälle. Für den harten Notfall. Absoluten Notfall. Das ist seit 2003 da glaube ich drin. Ein Fisherman's Friends. Das ist wie dieses, ich bin wie Jack Sparrow eigentlich. Ich habe einen Schuss noch und es ist die Frage, für wen ich das aufhebe. Ich habe einen Fisherman's Friends und ich muss für die richtige Situation aufgeben. Bei der Tausendjahre-Funkfeier hatte ich eine Visitenkarte, wurde mir vom Chef gegeben, um zu connecten. Man traut mir offensichtlich zu einen Kontakt. Ich hatte Visitenkarte, und die habe ich bis zum Ende aufgehoben, und ich wusste nicht genau, wie ich die geben sollte, weil das ist natürlich eine Verantwortung jetzt. Mehrere zu haben, ist kein Step. Du kannst die einfach rumschmeissen, schmeiß die Visitenkarte in den Club und schreien, äh, äh. Aber das war jetzt, war die Verantwortung natürlich da. Ja. Und da habe ich die am Ende einfach den Brandon-Typen gegeben. Aber das ist wie so ein Videospiel, wo du einen Heiltrank hast oder so, wo du mal
findest und den hast du einfach bis zum Ende des Spiels immer noch.
Und wenn die Credits laufen, hast du immer
noch deinen einen Heiltrank. Heiltränke?
Also, es gibt zwei
Arten Gamer. Die einen,
die... Die Stephans Game-Gake.
Lies den Control-Pad an
und schwingt euch das Aufford.
Wir haben mittlerweile viele Rocket Beans-Fans am Start. Ich glaube, ich mache mir jetzt nicht unbedingt Freunde mit meinem Halbgaben. Jetzt wird gezockt, Leute! Jetzt wird gedaddelt! Jetzt wird gedaddelt! Drückt auf die X und die Starts! Hoch, hoch, unten, links, Select! Mit Select betretet ihr jetzt die Gaming-Ecke. Ich glaube, es gibt zwei Arten von Leuten. Erstmal, es gibt die Leute, die Side-Quests machen und die nur die Health-Quests machen. Und es gibt Leute, die Heiltränke benutzen und die keine benutzen. Es gibt Leute, ich habe in meinem Leben noch keinen Heiltrank bei Pokémon benutzt. Noch keinen Trank. Stimmt. Naja, außer in den Top 4, wenn du da wirklich, da musst du schon Genese. Top 4, ach gut, das war hinten raus.
Beleber, alles da.
Aber noch schlimmer sind so Power-Ups irgendwie sowas.
Wenn du das nimmst, hast du für zwei Minuten weniger Erschöpfungs-Mali oder sowas.
Never ever benutze ich das so.
Weil wann ist das denn wichtig?
Oder du kannst zwei Minuten lang ein Stück schneller laufen.
Irgendwann wird es auch kompliziert.
Irgendwann werden auch die Erklärungen dann zu kompliziert für Items.
Du kannst zwei Sekunden lang schneller laufen, kannst aber die Attacke-V Vorsehung nicht benutzen, weil Schildkraft noch aktiviert ist. Okay, alles klar. Stopp, was muss ich würfeln? Ich habe keine Ahnung mehr. Escape. Gaming ist echt so ein Problem bei mir, weil ich war, ich spiele mir ein. Du bist schon ein Zocker, ne? Du hast eine PS2, hast du? Ich habe die PS2 und die Nintendo Wii und dann kennt mein Leben keine Grenze mehr. Und dann habe ich, weiß nicht, ich denke, Nintendo, ich war so gut in Spielen und dann treffe ich zum ersten Mal online auf Kontrahenten und merke, oh, ich war seit zehn Minuten tot, Wii Tennis ist gar nicht so meine Stärke. Jetzt muss ich aus dem Poesiealbum wieder rausstreichen bei meine Stärken. Kann ich dein Poesiealbum noch mal haben, bitte? Kann ich es noch mal haben? Ich würde gerne Wee Tennis rausstreichen bei Stärken. Das ist nicht mehr richtig. Bei Xing, ich biete Wee Tennis, nope. Stefan Tietze hat sein Profil geändert. We-Tennis ist nicht mehr so angestellt. Hat We-Tennis durch Minus ersetzt. Schwächs. Schwächs. Meine einzige Schwäche ist We-Tennis. Aber We-Tennis ist toll, ey. Die ganzen We-Spieler fand ich super, die ganzen We-Sports-Dinger. Ja, das war schon geil damals. Aber ich mag Bowling eher, Bowling war mein Ding. Das war super, ja. Ich weiss bis heute nicht, ob das wirklich stimmt. Ich habe mir da so eine ganz spezielle Technik ausgearbeitet, so mit Drall und so, und dann habe ich auch so Punkte, mir so Punkte gemacht, genau wo ich meinen Arm schwinge und so und wohin, aber es war immer ein anderes Ergebnis, es war auch so komplett, wo ich mir dachte, ich habe den Kopf nicht geknackt. Ich war mal richtig angepisst, ich hatte damals, da war so eine Kinderfrau, die auf mich aufgepasst hat, so eine Babysitterin.
Was?
So eine Babysitterin, die hat mich auf mich aufgepasst, als ich noch ganz klein war.
Und dann gab es Singstar und dann haben wir Singstar gegeneinander gespielt und sie war in einem Song besser als ich.
Und das habe ich nicht ertragen, dass sie in diesem Song besser ist.
Dann hast du Biggie Sack Buu gegründet.
Es war Eternal Flame, glaube ich, von Daido.
Nee, von der Tommy Kitten. Say my name You rain of all life So lonely. Ja, so. Jedenfalls war die besser und ich hab's nicht ertragen. Und dann hab ich das weinend den ganzen Abend noch gespielt. So habe das wirklich angestrengt,
weinend gespielt und das passt nicht zu Singstar.
Diese maximale Textinhaltschere,
unfassbar.
Ich war einfach, ich sass vor dem Schneidersitz,
angestrengt davor und habe versucht,
Eternal Flame maximal gut zu singen.
Und bei Singstar ist auch random, alles random.
Da kommt es sich auch an, du musst einen Text nicht singen. Also habe ich irgendwann erkannt, dass ich einfach einfach maximal versucht, möglichst diese Balken zu füllen. Scheiß auf den Text, scheiß auf die Melodie, hauptsache die Balken füllen. Und vor allem, es ist alles scheißegal, außer die gelben Balken. Der Rest ist vollkommen irrelevant. Die gelben Balken geben halt 200 Mal so viele Punkte. Also wirklich ein Millimeter auf dem gelben Balken ist so viel wert wie die acht Takte davor in grauen Balken. So einfach scheiß drauf. Aber es gibt ja auch immer so Pro-Gamer, so E-Sport, die halt dann mega krass Counter-Strike zocken oder so. Gibt es eigentlich eine Pro-Gamer-Singstar-Szene, wo dann halt so fette Nerds mit Fedoras dann singen, die auch nicht singen können, genau. Und die haben wirklich alles perfekt treffen, die das halt einfach durchgespielt haben. Aber so sah ich glaube ich auch so ein angestrengtes, nerviges Arschlochkind, was vor dem Fernseher saß und Daido gesungen hat. Und auch mit dem Oktavenwechsel war man immer... Und dann einfach versucht hat zu singen. Glaube ich ein lustiges Bild. Bei uns gab es sogar im Musikunterricht Noten auf SingStar. Oh ja, das hast du mal erzählt. Wie gut ist das eigentlich? Das war eigentlich ganz cool. Mega geil. Eigentlich ganz cool. Da hast du halt SingStar gespielt. Und dann gab es dann immer ... Der einfachste Song war immer Amy Winehouse' Black. Geil. Back to Black. Back to Black.
Der war ganz einfach, so dann haben wir alle genommen und dann einfach, und es ist halt auch so
pädagogisch ein bisschen
willkürlich, weil halt auch dann
zwei Leute vorne stehen und singen, so leise, wie sie
können, damit kein anderer Schüler sie hört.
Und alle anderen Schüler sitzen da und denken
sich so, das ist meine Jugend.
Ja, das wird
gemeint sein, wenn Leute sagen, die Jugend ist die schönste Zeit des Lebens. Ich sitze hier und schaue der dicken Bertra, schaue ich dabei zu, wie sie Bertra macht und ich sitze hier und mache nichts. Ich überlege gerade, was das Äquivalent ist in anderen Fächern. Das ist ein bisschen so, wenn man in Mathe irgendwie ein Sudoku löst. Ja, in etwa, ja. Mathe, Sudoku, Physik, Chemie, so einen Chemiebaukasten macht, in Physik einfach mal so ein Lego-Technik. In Physik so Bogenschießen einfach so, wir bauen uns einen Bogen. Ja, so Fischer-Technik, so ein Lego-ATS-D-Bauen oder so. Kann man irgendwas machen, was nicht Physik ist? Ja. Also der Physikunterricht ist ja schwer, weil es gibt nichts, was man nicht physikalisch besprechen kann. Ich dachte zwischenzeitlich, Antikapitation erfen erfunden zu haben, nämlich wenn man eine halbleere Flasche hochwirft, wird irgendwann der Inhalt nach oben geschleudert und die hat so einen leichten Hochdreil, so einen Umwucht, die es nach oben treibt.
Also siehst du das? Also ich werfe mal kurz die Flasche hoch.
Ja.
Siehst du, ich gebe nicht viel.
Wir laden den Griff hoch.
Ich gebe gar nicht viel Gaff dazu.
Ja, ja, ich merke schon, die Flasche fliegt von allein fast.
Ja, fliegt von allein hoch. Da habe ich mal kurz überlegt, Antigrafik-Tussend erfunden zu haben. Dem ist wahrscheinlich nicht so.
Aber es kann ja auch sein, dass du es tatsächlich erfunden hast und einfach Oxford, die tollen Herren von Oxford, da wieder nichts davon mitbekommen.
Weil sie einfach zu sehr in ihren Köpfen sind, weil sie zu verkopft denken, die Physiker, wie dieser Hawking.
Was kommt denn jetzt?
Stefan Titzes Imitation von dem Hawking.
Die Gaming-Ecke ist immer noch offen.
Wir haben drei Klammern offen, aber wir haben noch keine zugemacht.
Das ist kein Problem.
Über mehrere Folgen schon.
Wie du nimmst die Band mit Hawking? Ja, geht halt nicht. Hallo Mr. Hawking. Ich bin Stefan Titzel, ich habe Antikravitation erfunden. Wow, zäubig doch, sorry, mein Laptop ist aufgehangen. Stäubelung alt, entfernen. Das ist behindertenfeindlich. Feindlich? Das ist spastenfeindlich. So was kannst du nicht sagen. Mongofeindlich. Mongo-verachtend. Ey, ich fand diesen Film richtig respektlos über Stephen Hawking von Eddie Redmayne. Ich fand das echt scheiße, was die Leute aus dem Film gemacht haben. Ja, wisch dir mal die Tränen auf. Nee, weil in dem Film ging es nur darum, dass er behindert ist und dass er verliebt ist. Aber hallo, der Typ ist auch ein Physikgenie. Was hat er denn gemacht? So, anyone? Ich finde das so geil. Stephen Hawking ist mega, mega, mega erfolgreich in der Physik und mega berühmt. Aber versuch mal herunterzubrechen, wofür er genau steht. Ja, schwarze Löcher. Dunkle Materie hat er erfunden, Multiversum hat er erfunden, schwarze Löcher hat er erforscht. Ja, sorry, ich muss wie eine Physik-Genie sprechen. Je näher man kommt, desto stärker ist die Anziehungskraft. Wenige können hinunterbrechen, wofür er eigentlich steht. Aber du hast recht, natürlich, Gravitation, diese ganzen... Aber das finde ich ein bisschen respektlos. Wenn du einen Film machst über Stephen Hawking und dann zeigst du dir, der Typ ist behindert. So, ja, no shit. Aber der Typ ist ja nicht berühmt, weil er behindert ist, sondern weil er ein fucking Physikgenie ist. Und darüber ging es in dem Film überhaupt nicht. Und das fand ich, das ist echt scheiße. Stell dir mal vor, du bist der krasseste Physiker der Welt und merkst, oh, jetzt wird ein Film um mich gedreht, cool, schau ich mir an. Und dann geht es darum, wie du verliebt bist und behindert wirst. Dann denkst du dir, ja, Moment mal, hallo, habt ihr ein Buch von mir gelesen, womit ich mich beschäftige als Mensch? Dafür gab es auch Interstellar, toller Film. Aber ich kenne das ja, gut, ich kenne das ja mit oft werden erscheinen Artikel über mich, die einfach nicht genau treffen. Das stimmt, die einfach nicht treffen. Weil ich finde, du bist auch ein Typ zwischen den Zeilen. Das ist oft so, wenn man sich konkret fragt, was sagt Stefan Tietze eigentlich, was trägt er bei, dann wird es eng. Aber wenn man immer so macht, was ist so das Gefühl, das er vermittelt, die Atmosphäre, das was zwischen den Zeilen herrscht. Am besten gefiel mir die Überschrift, dass... Hat stille Ideen. Naja, fand ich auch nicht schlecht, ich fand darüber auch gut. Ein Spongebob-Schwammkopf-Fan hat Erfolg mit Witzens für Böhmermann. Das war die, aus einer Schweizer Zeitung. Ja, aber ich fasse so, Stefan Tietze hat viele Ideen, auch so nicht spezifiziert, welche Ideen, so hat viele Konzeptideen, so Serviervorschläge oder sowas, welche Ideen genau sind das, die er hat einfach so, hat schmutzige Ideen, hat viele Ideen. Also, was denn? In seinem Kopf geht viel Vorsicht. Ja, genau. Ja, Stefan Tietze denkt nach. Aha. Stefan Tietze hat Ideen einfach. Das finde ich schon echt gut. Glaubst du nicht? Oh, ich habe einen Vorschlag zu machen. Ich finde, wir müssen mal mehr Ratschläge geben. Also einfach mal Ratschläge, Lebensweisheiten, Podcast-Ufo, Lebensweisheiten, auch mal auf Shirts, da müssen wir mal in den Shirts denken, Leute, ich denke ja auch ein bisschen an so Popmonik. Wie wär's mit dem Shirt, das ist ein Shirt, also das ist ein T-Shirt, das sollte man auf ein T-Shirt drucken, aber halt der Ersatz auf ein T-Shirt. Das sollte man mal auf ein T-Shirt drucken. Das sollte man mal auf ein T-Shirt drucken. Genau, so, das sollte man mal auf ein T-Shirt drucken.
Genau, so. Das sollte man mal auf ein T-Shirt drucken.
Sprudshirt. Sprudshirt.
Folgende Weisheit.
Stephans Weisheit, Nummer eins.
Benutze stets ein Ladekabel, wenn es sich dir erbietet.
Ja.
Du weißt nie, wann du in einer Ladekabel-Durchstrecke landest.
Ich will es anders formulieren.
Benutze nie ein Ladekabel nicht. Wenn du die Möglichkeit hast, benutze es Ladekabel-Dossstrecke landest. Ich will es anders formulieren, benutze nie ein Ladekabel nicht.
Wenn du die Möglichkeit hast, benutze das Ladekabel.
Das Ding ist, ich sitze oft am Schreibtisch, das Ladekabel ist eingesteckt, in einer Steckdose, aber nicht in meinem Laptop.
Das ist falsch, Leute.
Ja, gut, aber ich bin mobiler Typ, ich habe mein Ladekabel in meinem Rucksack, wie schon angesprochen.
Richtig, aber du weißt nicht, benutze es stets, wenn in einer Steckd, Ladekabel und Laptop vor dir sind. Immer benutzen, auch bei iPhone. Du kannst es ja nicht überladen und ihr werdet auch keinen Strom mehr benutzen, als ihr braucht. Aber jetzt möchte ich mal ganz kurz, ich bin ja in den 90er Jahren aufgewachsen, ich bin 90s-Kid. Ja, ich kenne noch Pongs und Digimon-Karten und Yo-Gi-Oh!-Karten und all das. Night. Night fever, night fever! Ich wollte ein bisschen Backgroundmusik für die 90s machen. Tell me more, tell me more, did you put up a fight? Ah, ich liebe die 90er. New York, New York! Ah, geil, die 90er. Mrs. Robinson, ah, wie großartig. Das war das beste Jahrzehnt. Ja. Born in the USA. I'm on the highway to hell. Ah, das war eine Zeit, ey. Das war geil. Alba. Wow. Und in den 90ern gab es diesen Mythos des Domino-Effekts.
Ja, Domino Day!
Damit hat es aber nichts zu tun, sondern damit, dass wenn man einen Akku auflädt, der noch nicht ganz entladen ist,
dann verkürzt sich die maximale Ladedauer und die Kapazität des Akkus.
Und das hat sich so in mein Gehirn eingebrannt, dass ich mir immer denke, Geräte müssen erst ganz leer werden, bis ich sie wieder neu aufladen darf. Stimmt das denn? Also ganz kurz, Stefan, stimmt das denn? Oder ist das veraltet? Ich komme aus einer alten Elektrikerfamilie und mir wurde mal gesagt, bevor du etwas, bevor ich, ich habe immer ein Telefon bekommen zum ersten Mal, hieß es, du musst es erst einmal komplett leer telefonieren. Ja, genau. Und dann neu aufladen und dann nochmal, glaube ich, und dann irgendwann ist es erst reif. Daran kann ich mich auch erinnern, ja. So, aber das Problem ist, jetzt komme ich aus einer Elektrikerfamilie und es ist wirklich anscheinend wissenschaftlich irgendwie fundiert. So, und dann habe ich das natürlich immer gemacht. Das mache ich immer noch. Wenn ich ein iPhone bekomme, mache ich es erst ganz leer und dann leistet es mir erst mal auf. Ist aber, glaube ich, kompletter Quatsch.
Ich glaube, das ist veralterter, aber das ist tatsächlich, das ist so ein Ding, weil wir kommen ja jetzt schon langsam in ein Alter, wo wir nichts mehr Neues lernen, wo wir einfach haben, okay, wir haben das, was wir haben, Setup, so, das war es einfach so. Das sind jetzt die fünf Items, die du auf die Insel mitgenommen hast. Ich merke das auch, du willst das nicht mehr von mir lernen.
Ich nehm das nicht an.
Ich wollte neulich Adblocker installieren, du hast einfach gesagt, nein, nein, ich habe, ich kenne Bild.de mit der Werbung nach rechts. Nein, mir kommt das nicht in meinen Browser. Es ist tatsächlich so, dass ich Adblocker habe und oft schicken mir Leute Links zu Süddeutsche.de und dann klicke ich das an und dann so Adblocker und dann denke ich mir, ja dann lese ich es nicht und dann schreibe ich zurück, haha, lustig. Und dann war das halt ein Artikel über Trump fängt jetzt an, irgendwie auch Weisse zu deportieren. Was geht denn jetzt gerade ab? Deportiert er gerade alle?
Megageil. Ich glaube, das ist dein Karriereende. Ich glaube, deine Lüge ist dein Karriereende.
Was ist jetzt los? Jetzt kommen mir die Züge vorgefallen.
Hey, hä, was ist denn das? Kann ich Ihnen helfen? Müllabfuhr. Das ist doch nicht Müllabfuhr. Na wer hat denn da Pockt? Get this in a? Das war doch auch immer das Spannendste. Damals im Schwimmbad, damals in den 90ern, ja. And it burn, burn, burn, the ring of fire.
Man ist schön im Schwimmbad mit seinen Eltern und plötzlich kommt die Durchsage, der Besitzer des Wagens M482A möchte bitte seinen Wagen entfernen.
Alle so gucken.
Möchte er das wirklich?
Wer steht auf?
Und da wir in den 90ern sind, singen sie weiter We Will Rock You, indem sie ihre Hände zunächst auf ihre Oberschenkel klatschen und dann einmal richtig. Das ganze Schlimmste. 90er, 90er. Ja, das stimmt. Vor allem auch die Feuerwehrzufahrt hat auch schon für viele Unruhen gesorgt bei mir damals. Weil ich auch Feuerwehr, die haben mich magisch angezogen. Ich liebe persönlich Feuerwehreinfahrten. Da zu parken... Ist der beste Parkplatz. Ist der beste Parkplatz einfach. Und du weißt, du bist sicher, weil die Feuerwehr ist in der Nähe. Auch, es gibt Städte, unter anderem eine Heimatstadt, die hat so viele Behindertenparkplätze. Mehr als Behinderte. Mehr als Behinderte da. Was soll das? Das ist unmöglich. Diese Behindertenquote. Ey, wenn das die Behindertenquote ist... Das ist eine Wunschvorstellung. Von der Stadt. Eine Wunschvorstellung. Dann ist wirklich, dann ist die Walking Dead, dann ist die Innenstadt komplett, dann ist komplett nur noch ein Meer aus Mongos, ein Mongomere.
Einfach eine Riesen, das ist wirklich nur noch.
Aber wenn die Stadt so aussähe, dann wäre die im Guinness-Buch der Rekorde.
Es gäbe Touristen, die da hinkommen würden, um Fotos von der Mongo-Innenstadt zu machen.
So Rewe, einfach steht brach, die Kassiererinnen verstehen gar nichts mehr, so eine große Saber-Pfützen überall. Aber es gibt auch irgendwo in Finnland oder in Schweden so eine Alzheimer-Stadt, wo die so eine ganze Fake-Stadt gebaut haben, mit ganz vielen Betreuern, wo lauter Leute mit Alzheimer sind, die halt den ganzen Tag immer dasselbe machen, aber da halt so betreut sind. Zehn Minuten Radio-Rotation, zehn Minuten Fernseh-Rotation. Immer dieselbe Werbung. Die kaufen, bringen es nach Hause, kaufen, bringen es den ganzen Tag. Wie gut ist das denn? Mega gut, total cool. Weil die checken ja selber nicht, dass sie Alzheimer haben. Okay, die checken alles da. Die sind ja zu dumm, um das zu verstehen. Aber angenommen, die Alzheimer-Kassiererin und die Alzheimer-Oma, die da jetzt kauft, sind in einem Zehn-Minuten-Rodation gefangen. Dann irgendwann ist die Oma arm. Ich glaube, das System Alzheimer-Innenstadt kann nicht funktionieren, glaube ich. Aber da hat mir auch so eine Behindertenstadt, wo alle behindert sind, wo dann einfach Armageddon ist. Einfach weil das einfach nicht funktioniert. Wo die Gehbehinderten wahrscheinlich Könige sind einfach, weil die noch zumindest mal halb in der Birne alles das im Schrank haben. Aber da möchte ich sagen, das ist ein interessanter psychologischer Ein bisschen aufgestachelt gegenseitig. Aber das ist ein interessantes psychologisches Experiment, wenn jemand sagt, der Besitzer des Kennzeichens irgendwas, weil niemand kennt sein Kennzeichen auswendig. Und alle denken, wenn jetzt niemand aufsteht, ist es mein. Das ist deine Prämisse des Bits jetzt, dass niemand sein Kennzeichen auswendig kennt. Natürlich, ich kenne mein Kennzeichen nicht. Klar, easy. Was sind deine Kennzeichen? UN-ST-100. UN von Unna. Ja, Unna-ST-100. So, jetzt könnt ihr einfach Stefan Titzel track. Das glaube ich nicht. Mit dem Kennzeichen. Ey, du hast morgen einen Flashmob von deiner Tür. 100 pro Cent. 100. Ich wollte nicht zu cool klingen. Ich darf nie zu cool klingen. 100 Promille. Ich bin mir nicht sicher. Ich bin mir nicht sicher genug. Alter, 1000 Promille. Ey, 1000 Promille, mit der den Ball jetzt rein versenken. Ich bin mir nicht so sicher. Das ist eigentlich eine schöne Figur, so der Mega-Assi, der aber so komisch technische Formulierungen benutzt. Ey, in hundert von hundert Fällen ballert der den in die Ecke. Alter, ey, ich geb mir voll Kanter heute, ich kann nicht nichts, die Deziliter einfach weg. Die Deziliter. Ich schenk's mir nur zehn Deziliter ein. Das war auch der größte Nonsens in der Schule. Einfach so diese Dezimeter. Was? Nein, niemand nutzt das. Das ist eine komische Zwischeneinheit. Ja, das sind halt zehn Zentimeter. Aber da musste man dann immer so ein Kubikzentimeter in Kubikdezimeter umrechnen. So, wo wir denken, es fehlt zwischen Zentimeter und Meter kein Einheit. Nichts, ja. Es fehlt nichts. Das ist ja nicht so, dass er sagt, Cent und zehn Cent sind dann nochmal ein Blinger. Dezent. Dezent, sagst du. Ah, ja, vielen Dank Stefan Tietze für diese Krabbeneinlage. Vielen Dank auch für deinen Sinspruch. Nächste Woche, glaube ich, wird nicht mehr. Auf jeden Fall. Wir möchten euch auf jeden Fall auch weiterbringen im Leben, dass ihr ein bisschen was mitnehmt, dass ihr nicht immer nur Patreon, Blecht, Blecht, Blecht, Geld ausgibt und nichts dafür bekommt. Nein, ihr bekommt tolle T-Shirt-Ideen, die nicht umgesetzt werden, die in euren Köpfen existieren, aber nicht auf eurer Haut und natürlich tolle Weisheitssprüche.
Vielen Dank an Stefan Tietze.
Vielen Dank an Florantin Wild für diese Woche.
Ja komm nächste Woche mal wieder vernünftig in einem vernünftigen Raum mit der vernünftigen Atmosphäre.
Ja das war Quatsch heute.
Das war Quatsch.
Bis zur nächsten Woche.
Macht's gut.
Sorry, unsere Behinderten-Zuschauer.
Ciao.
Ciao, ciao.
Ciao, ihr Trottel.